in other news North Carolina election
officials ordered a do-over in the
country's lat last undecided
congressional race after a dramatic
change of heart by the leading candidate
Republican Mark Harris conceded
yesterday his 905 vote lead was tainted
by possible election fraud his reversal
followed Jay's of sometimes emotional
testimony about alleged misdeeds by a
political operative working for his
campaign David beg no is at the State
Capitol in Raleigh David good morning
beyond a good morning let me set the
scene for you the congressional
candidates son gets on the stand and
says I told my mom and my dad an email
and on the phone that something seems
shady about this one man and I was
suspicious about what was going on
apparently the candidate Mark Harris
didn't know the son was going to say
that on the stand and didn't know that
the emails would be entered into
evidence so when the candidate got on
the stand right as he was about to be
cross-examined with that evidence he
asked for a break and when they came
back from a break the candidate said I
had two recent strokes
I made some missed statements and I'm
having trouble remembering things this
becomes clear to me the public's
confidence in the district see general
election has been undermined to an
extent it was a stunning reversal by
Republican Mark Harris following four
days of witness testimony about claims
of ballot fraud allegedly involving this
man McCray Dallas who Harris hired to
get out the vote Dallas was accused of
hiring workers to illegally collect
absentee ballots forged voter and
witness signatures and in some cases
fill out ballots for Republican
candidates yesterday Harris testified in
front of the Board of Elections that he
was unaware of any concerns regarding
Dallas but the tipping point was his son
who testified earlier in the week mark
Harris looked on in tears as his son
John who is an attorney himself said he
repeatedly warned his dead the younger
Harris had said that on the phone and in
emails his father realizing he was going
to be questioned about it admitted Mis
statements and said
health issues had affected his memory he
asked the board for a new election so
yeah the head of North Carolina's GOP
Dallas Woodhouse said the outcome is
devastating do you think that a new
election is the right decision I think
what we have stated is we support dr.
Harris's decision to call for a new
election but is that the right decision
I think because he called for it it is
the right decision the attorney for the
Democrat candidate called the decision a
win for the North Carolina voters they
will have an opportunity to have a free
and fair election that is not the
product of fraud or taint now you know
who people really want to hear from
McCray Dallas the man at the center of
the investigation he claims he's
innocent but Gail he refused to testify
at the hearing so what's next a brand
new election and they're going all the
way back to the beginning the primary
but we don't know if mr. Harris is going
to run again at the end of the day Gail
the 9th district is not being
represented in Congress there is nobody
in that seat while this situation gets
figured out more to come on this story
interesting dynamic between father and
son thank you very much David